[Music]
are you in Nick on good terms right now
Oh Lord um how do I say that in the most
mature manner possible I'm not friends
with Nick so I'll just say that and I
get along with a lot of people so that's
all I wish him nothing but the best of
course like you know we're two very
different people when it comes to a lot
of different things so but he has a
great opportunity right now to find
somebody and I hope it works out for him
Andy is gonna be back on Nick's a season
it seems she might be returning uh what
do you think of that I think they're
perfect for each other to be honest with
you knowing both of the people and who
they are they should have ended up
together what does that mean perfect
house I just I I know both of them a
little bit and I just think they're
perfect for each other
that's all I think they should try to
kind of get back together we've also
heard she's working on another book what
are your thoughts on that do you think
you might be in another book if she
wrote who knows and honestly it really
doesn't matter to me that's her way of
making money and stuff like that so
that's great and if I've got to you know
be the person to you know the fall guy
for everything and whatever her her
stories are then whatever I'm not
worried about her and I'm not worried
about that I try to separate myself from
the negativity just deal with positive
people and good people and she's
definitely not one of those would you
write a book have you thought about this
I've been asked I've been asked to write
a book for sure and obviously it's very
tempting to do stuff and it's very
tempting to tell the truth if I wrote a
book it wouldn't be a negative book
attacking people in their character and
trying to bring them down just because
you're bitter so so is that why you
hadn't written it cuz that's a people
100% I mean that's what sells right
drama sells whether it's TV and people
wanting to create drama or or books in
general you know if I have something
than it needs to be well thought need to
be a positive look yes it can have some
truths in it but not something where it
it hurts that other person in any way no
matter how I feel cuz believe me there
could be a book written that would be
very very bad but that's not something
that I would want to do
you